[Music]
hi everyone and welcome to Friday face
off with Miki kay project manager here
at glamour and winner of blow up Ellis
Atlantis hi everyone we have 5 minutes
to complete this look we don't know what
the look is but we do know it's gonna be
Pride themed so it's gonna be a bit of a
surprise but I'm hoping for glitter
anything ramble I go for emboli a
rainbow cut crease like so let's find
out what the looks going to be oh I'm
gonna rainbow you definitely got rainbow
but you you got David Bowie meets
rainbow the classic glam that I can do
the liner and the red lip right the
rainbow oh I just thought how we do it
in five minutes
I guess we better get on with it then
yeah let's get started have you got like
a liquid or a pencil got this Chanel
pencil oh I feel like a white liquid
which is like an array of the kind of
thing oh no i've also got white liquid
yeah
I've got this mark feels so good matte
liquid lipstick yeah I just melt this
Mac with it looks just more like like a
oh I do okay
[Music]
okay I'm just gonna go with getting this
massive zigzag on my face
okay so I'm just using this too now
white eyeliner stick to like do the
outline I feel like I've already gone
wrong Bobby started with so much share
my pal now I'm removing my brow you're
leaving your brow I'm panicking a bit
I'm not gonna lie I'm just winging it I
don't really know what I am doing this
is terrible
have you got this Illamasqua palette
thing yeah I'm getting the purple like
what I'm doing purple I'm like mixing
two together green I'm just gonna have
to this is terrible I need to pick up
the pace
I literally himself a chair I'm hungry
now so I got purple blue and green on Oh
and now we're gonna go with this brush
is good I know what you thought I was
like I want to be sick of there so give
it so good oh I'm actually it's
reassuring that you're struggling too
that gives me hope because you're the
professional here
no just get it on and hope for the best
have you done your lips no I'll just
kind of go
I'm just doing what I know how to do and
that's apply lipstick I've literally got
a lightning bolt it's coming together
ah I look like a child did it but I can
hear my god oh my god the color I'm
gonna try and blend black bit into the
orange it's have you put eyeliner on Oh
how we've soaked up we've got lashes to
do as Wow
oh my god I've never done an eyeliner so
fast have you got lashes on yeah what
the hell I could cry this is so bad oh
[Music]
my god I think I'm gonna forget lashes
and I'm just gonna put on mascara and I
need time to do that I need like No
[Music]
oh my god you're just a good uses so
good this is really unfair yours is so
good this is I don't have about me I
feel like I've been set up
yours is really good although to be fair
though we're so powerful you have any
perdition I panicked it went even your
lips like how your lips boys coming on
this is brilliant fair this is yeah this
is yeah yeah so guys thanks for watching
glamour UK's Friday faceoff if you liked
the video don't forget to give it a
thumbs up and comment down below what
looks you want to see them try now and
if you want to see more videos like this
then don't forget to subscribe to
glamour UK's YouTube channel and have a
fun Pride